think I [ __ ] while I was walking I was
on the I went on a cruise
I think I just should have kept walking
that's the way you do it you know
because because I was because the next
day in the room I was like what smells
in this thing
what are those things
and I'm like oh man that's that's a lot
of [ __ ] pina coladas with with a
fireball floater
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
by Keith Phelps have a new sport Sports
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
[Music]
um Michael uh Rosenbaum um I think did
you have the first podcast
in the world you know I've been doing a
podcast I think you have to be one of
one of the um I think you have to be one
of the innovators though I've had it
forever I wouldn't say innovator but I I
you know it's been like five years
something like that yeah not that long
there's a lot of people oh yeah I gotta
open it first right I haven't makes it
easier to drink cheers cheers for having
me hey let me tell you this is whose
beer is this mine this is your own beer
you know you've made it my own beer I'm
not uh
I think when the year starts we won't be
drinking this anymore
I can give you an inside of you keychain
a podcast but yeah look I gotta be
honest it started out as one of my
friends saying hey you got a good voice
and you know a lot of other actors and
you can make a lot of money it's just
whoa that that part I can make some
money so I started doing the podcast not
you know just trying to be
and it's harder than it looks in the
beginning there weren't that many
listeners right but once I started to
open up and say [ __ ] it and just be weak
and I say F yeah and just really
vulnerable like talking about depression
anxiety dysfunctional family growing up
and I started to know a lot of people
started you know gravitating towards the
podcast because it helps with mental
health talking not just celebrity
[ __ ] but like real [ __ ] yeah so it's
uh you know some people on the show have
cry like Zach Levi right uh Jennifer
Love Hewitt
um Stephen and Mel had an anxiety attack
on the podcast yeah yeah so it's crazy
it's uh I never thought I would love
what I what I what I'm doing now and do
you do it at your house yeah I got a
studio at my house yeah so it's cool and
a lot of people know where I live though
at least started crying on the Pod the
first one I did here Bobby Lee yeah
Bobby Lee started crying he started
crying they picked up his T-shirt and
cleaned himself off he's talking about
his dad yes we were talking about my dad
and you know what how I wanted all I
wanted life was making and he sits there
and he starts right he's a [ __ ]
stop he said you know make me you're
making me cry and he was Yeah clean his
tears off isn't that funny what are
those things what are those things that
no matter how
how old you get like it stays on the
surface huh like things that can just
you know I want to meet the community
really you know since I've met you and
others that have come on I want to meet
the comedian that didn't have problems
because it seemed like there's something
deep inside most of you that have come
out uh
I think it all starts from
well I mean from your grandma
I mean Bobby Lee you know Bobby Lee's
not dating I guess he was dating yeah
they broke up they broke up on the air I
think but when I oh [ __ ] but when I went
and did this podcast she talked about
her making out with her uncles in
backyard party and I thought
what do you mean she's gonna fall out
[ __ ] dancing tongue kissing I said
hold you 13.
that's got to mess up I mean that's
gonna mess you was [ __ ] dancing and
type of cutting down
what the [ __ ] I mean they talked about
it with such and I was like
wow man that's so
just so open I don't you know not like
us like I don't know if I want to if I
want to say that she's like I used to
make out with my uncles at the at the
party oh so you did make backyard
parties yeah no you go out of my phone
yeah
I guess but it's like me talking Grandma
at the train station ain't that bad then
huh I was already an adult yeah
I mean it's just I mean what how would
you define the air in a podcast
open platform you know you talk about
[ __ ] three words
you can go to therapy and you can figure
yourself out people say well grow up you
know you're not you had a childhood but
you grow up and you become a man and you
you move on right but it's easier said
than done there's still things that
inner child that comes out that you you
know I lied to my therapist you're
supposed to light it up there I know it
happened I've done it before I mean
you're not supposed to because if you're
gonna get well you got to go all in yeah
and you're spending money for no reason
hey you're just you're lying to somebody
you can't help you if you're lying what
about now do you do it now you still
don't tell the truth right you still
alive uh well we're past those issues
but I uh
oh
are you a big jack off I mean I was
really yeah
you don't spank it I did don't snap now
guys 73 years old it's rejecting my head
I think when you're older it's sadder
you're an old man jacking off as well be
in the Park yeah well I end up falling
asleep yeah or yeah I have ADD in most
of them so I'm jerking off and then I'm
like oh my God
yeah there's never enough lube and you
know what I watch I watch [ __ ] porno
from the seven
I'm not even watching porno from [ __ ]
now John Leslie all the [ __ ]
are all dead because you like the hair I
don't know what I like they're like you
know oh I know that street that [ __ ]
van hoe and you're like oh they filmed
it all in the valley yeah hey that's
that's Canoga Park High you're like you
know you're not even watching porn
anymore you're going oh that [ __ ]
place ain't there anywhere that stereo
place [ __ ] [ __ ] do you watch porn did
you already know any porn stars
yeah I did a short film with one I'm
trying to remember my friend James Gunn
who's now the head of DC did a sports
film uh and it's called PG porn and I
played they did a peanuts episode that
penis since I was bald I played Charlie
Brown yeah and I'm trying to think who
is in it she's a big she was a big porn
star for a while oh we didn't have to
kiss her not Jenna no oh no it wasn't
her I gotta remember let me let me text
because you know
put
I think porn you know I think porno
people are like what sculptors used to
be in Rome
really it's like nobody can stop
nobody's a sculptor you know you got to
be you got to be living to be a [ __ ]
sculpted like that their whole life is
[ __ ]
peladonna that's it what's your name
Belladonna no Bella oh I can tell you
there was a scene with her with a
baseball bat
yeah that's all I'll say and I was like
an aluminum Battery
Plus Louisville Slugger and [ __ ]
swing him for the fence wow yeah I mean
do you have a bat in your ass you just
drive home baby I'll stop against get
some loot for the best if I can stir fry
I feel like maybe having stir fry
tonight they had a [ __ ] bat in your
oil they're [ __ ] turning it you know
like blowing glass [ __ ] then [ __ ]
turn into it
you know there's no way she's ever
constipated no way
to just falling out when she farts
there's got to be a
hey you're right's here
yeah I mean that's their [ __ ] life is
sex sex porn do you think they love it
or yeah or do you have to love it or you
think it's just really a job they're
just going through the motions
what do you think
I think it's
I think it might be I think you know
combination they gotta like it in order
to do it you know to get some kind of
sensation on it how much is this [ __ ]
paid did they pay more I don't know now
I think you know you can watch it all on
YouTube it's all free it's all free man
how are they getting paid that's what I
wonder I think because on those ads it's
like get your dick bigger yeah for this
you know when people click that and they
get a piece of there's all these little
things yeah it doesn't work not that
I've ever clicked but are you tired of
watching porn [ __ ] no [ __ ] you have
to wait for this [ __ ] to skip ads come
on get out of the way
you know and
um
I've known a lot of them well you know
when I had my talk show we we brought
one on and then she sent me
uh like roses but they're like cookies
they still do that [ __ ] like edibles but
they're like a rose oh yeah [ __ ]
how about that stuff and I'm like is she
sending me what what the what what am I
what's going on and she said she liked
me I was like I you know the question is
could you if somebody was paying you
said you're gonna have sex but also they
choose like today you're gonna have sex
with this person right like you have to
be what if you're not attracted I don't
think I could I don't I mean with Cialis
or Viagra enough could that I think your
mind still has to want to do it yeah and
you know yeah and they have a fluffer
like that's got to be the worst job ever
to stand in a [ __ ] chair over here
I got caught in traffic sorry come over
here yeah what is she like the bar back
or the bar boy he gets like they they
tip out at the end yeah it's a small
percentage Yeah they tap the thing on
the like the biggest thanks
I don't know but Ron Jeremy was uh uh in
my dressing room I don't know how
[ __ ] myself at Microsoft
and
he had like sleep in his eyes it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] 10 30 at night either
he's coming out of his [ __ ] uh I I
suck in here he had like two [ __ ]
peas right here he's like man this dude
is nasty and my papa sister she's like
get that [ __ ] out of your
dressing room really and we had to get
you had to ask him to get out
was he embarrassed yeah but I mean he's
just like some felon [ __ ] wandering
around backstage at Microsoft how the
[ __ ] does he get in there wow
he was the man he was the man back in
the day I always remember going that's
what he just got in trouble with the law
not too long this woman never got out of
jail yeah what did he do somebody was
accusing yeah really yeah I know that
being yeah action cut you cut cut way to
bring that up yeah yeah no I mean yeah
he's he's
but also also
somebody can say something about you and
that can't be true and then they protect
them and then you're not protected yeah
if it was somebody that said I'll get
you [ __ ] you'll see then they
they file a complaint has to be
investigated gets on the gets in TMZ or
whatever and then everybody can say
anything you're [ __ ] done
I hope that's on the way out no now
people are giving me a little bit more
like hey hey you can't just throw
everything he did this and his career's
over without it right you know you just
can't do that to people and then all of
a sudden all of a sudden if they say
they go talk to your neighbors or like
I'm [ __ ] you're gonna talk to your
neighbors go so it's always was did he
go out or not no he was oh he was home a
lot you see any people go in and out ah
once in a while I mean it just all
sounds bad ah once in a while some kids
would go over there yeah
what time would the kids leave I don't
know if they ever left you're like oh
man what the come on do they have ski
masks [ __ ] kids
somebody's been running they were
supposed to be running a whorehouse uh
just a couple blocks away from my house
my daughter came when she was Dad it's
all over the bus they're doing out of
that house so I went by there a couple
of times just to check it out I didn't
see traffic [ __ ] but they the guy
eventually
moved out you know they got him out of
the out of the area and uh when you're
sex trafficking people how do you get
them not to just cut out
like after they do somebody's Nails oh
I'm gonna wash my hands for the next
person they'd run out the back yeah how
do you how do they stay put I don't know
I don't know like they threaten you or I
haven't because they say a lot of those
massage partners and a lot of stuff it's
all people that are
sex sex trafficking people how about the
weirdos who like I have a massage
therapists and I asked her once again
you get any weirdos and she's like
yeah I go well tell me and she goes well
sometimes they think it's
all in yeah you know like they get the
extra she goes hey can I get I'll give
you extra and she's like no she's like
oh come on and it makes him feel
uncomfortable and I've heard some like
stars that have done that like come on
come on come on and I was like what like
crazy there was there was a guy who
um
there's a huge actor that was playing at
the Dunhill cup and at the Saint Andrews
hotel rusacks where they play the the
you know old courses right there he went
for a massage and tried to get one of
them to do it and she wouldn't do it and
he got thrown out but like up the
tournament out of the hotel everything
wow and I mean that's the idea that so
you would think well maybe
I know who I am maybe you know they know
who I am maybe it's okay but it's like
that's just it's sexist whatever makes
you feel good I learned that and that
was a definition yeah so so people
because it's weird to somebody else you
know where do you may not be weird or
somebody else and I I did have uh a
murder we thought it was a John because
it was a prostitute who got killed so we
started going picking up all the all the
working [ __ ] in the area
and we had the first one take us to the
next one going to the next one and
knocked on an apartment uh just a hotel
knocked the hotel door shows who is it
broad says it's me she opens up and
there's some other female in there one
of her working compatriots and ugly had
her wig off the wigs off she's sitting
there eating Colonel Sanders chicken and
she says well these he said don't worry
they're they're cops they're good it's
Gill and Ike it's we going there we
start talking to her but look at we're
here working the murder because it's
your friend that's out there dead so we
want to find out who we think it's a
John
and if you have anybody weird everybody
gets pissed off she said no I got one
regular and uh he likes me to dump on
him and you know didn't know the word
dump is that dump your problems tell me
your problems what was going so we can
finish areas okay let's get back to that
dump what do you mean dumb
and she says you know right here on a
chip oh [ __ ] right on his chest
Cleveland steamer and that's what it's
called I think so it went deeper and
when he can't when we can't when I can't
perform he gets a little upset but he
doesn't start beating me up or anything
he says he's really a nice guy and he
works for says something Unified School
District right here on his arm
God I mean how do you get that how do
you get
how do you get word that's a turnout
here it comes it's [ __ ] coming out I
think you know what I think it is I'm
not an expert but I think some people
act actually you know people are sex
addicts it's like an addiction with
anything yeah sure drugs right and some
people have done so much and done
everything that they're like what else
would be completely provided it's called
Naughty and they just step it up you've
got places that we would never think of
yeah I think you got to go to the next
place it's called Corporal acne There's
an actual term for it and when I was a
Cadet in the academy you have to come
back they'd send you out on weekend to
ride with regular cops then you come
back on money and you dealt with
anything go on special where you were
out there and somebody worked Malibu and
when they went to Malibu they had these
uh outhouses but they had under you
could actually go in underneath like on
a hill and you could go in underneath if
they had to do anything to change the
buckets or do whatever and he says we
actually caught a guy what he was doing
he was sneaking in there when people are
going to take it down
and that was his thing like masturbating
no no they were letting him [ __ ] on him
oh he went underneath so somebody's
asses write a book and they're taking it
up in the shower what this is true yeah
yeah can this be edited out man who is
that oh my God I have no idea though
[ __ ] I was 21 years old in the academy
it happened over his mouth no the cop
didn't go in there they arrested yeah
yeah yeah yeah but uh he was doing that
there wait so they arrested him with
[ __ ] all over him yeah you can't you
didn't you don't watch that's the worst
job to have to go arrest that guy oh
some of the people you run into were
terrible
you ever seen anybody during the day
that you they like they're [ __ ] wigs
[ __ ] sideways and they got [ __ ]
red lips and you know they're they're
made for like the middle of the night
like they're not made for the day yeah
and they're just [ __ ] you're like
what the [ __ ] is with this person man
and you look at them and they're all
[ __ ] thing with a wig it's all
[ __ ] sideways and they're gonna pay
and then they [ __ ] like sink like
[ __ ] slide off and you're like
wow that's the crazy thing is you look
at someone you have no idea no idea what
the [ __ ] they could look clean exactly
exactly and they could be the darkest
[ __ ] you've ever known yeah and it's
just like that yeah that's why you can't
really trust anybody it's crazy man that
guy from that reporter from channel five
that oh yeah OD'd in that hotel like he
I I went over to the fair I did the fair
and the restaurant was there and then he
was the guy in the morning just seemed
like the tall guy he you know from a
family friendly guy
you know perfect at announcing and then
you know it was that guy and you're like
wow man that's I don't know I mean it's
such a facade anyways but yeah
um and when they found they first
announced they had found him
I told my wife and my daughter I said
in a hotel dope and gay [ __ ] yeah you
know where he was at there's absolutely
no reason for him to be in that area
because you know they always nope and
gay but you know like you said like you
know you can get a little bit sideways
and more and more and more you know
when I'm not complaining about the gauge
the dope got him but right you could see
no no but also if you're like when
money's new to you you go and do things
and
you you you're doing stuff that is new
to you and then it's something else and
then
it's just a kind of a [ __ ] feeds on
its own especially if you have some any
kind of mental that's sort of like you
have like any kind of schizophrenia or
any kind of bipolar manic depressive
right you know they say when people are
really manic they just go on spending
you know and drinking and drugs and all
they can they can go nuts for those
things so it's like
there's so many
you know there's so many different
people with
many problems that we couldn't even
understand how the [ __ ] Matthew Perry
takes 70 [ __ ] biking in a day and is
that true do you really can't you can't
you can't even Elvis would be that's
some [ __ ] man you can't 70. I
remember I had I had a lot of back
surgeries and I remember you know taking
like two every six hours so
six spills a day but seven seven is
there is there a way
and then also you know I took I took a
half a biking and we did a show and then
I was drinking having a drink back in
the back and I was still in front of
people and I don't even remember like
even the next day I think Cedric was on
stage and I got him off early and he was
like Hey man uh you got me off early and
I said did I and I was out of my [ __ ]
head man like on a half of Vikings and a
drink yeah I can't imagine that amount
I've got a high pain threshold and I
very seldom even if that knee
replacement kidney gone I've never taken
pain pills really yeah you know what I
have an addiction too
this is gonna sound weird so I don't do
drugs I rarely drink I mean I in the
past I've done stuff when I was you know
younger and stupid
but so I have a you know my back's not
always great you know a lot of surgery
so
some people are scared when they get put
under
I love it
I love anesthesia
yeah or yeah
um but I always ask anesthesiologists I
said listen I I'm like a drug addict
because I go hey look I don't do drugs I
don't drink I'm like I'm I you know
can you just make me can I feel it a
little longer yeah can I just feel it a
little longer and feel good for just a
few minutes because yeah of course so I
do it and I wake up and I'm like what
the [ __ ] man you said I could let you
feel it he goes why don't you check your
phone
and I had like a five minute video of me
going hey she had no clue what the hell
was happening that's what happens yeah
they give it to you I was up for a few
minutes and I was making the whole all
this everybody's [ __ ] laughing I'm
doing Krista for walking and like you
know all these impersonations and
they're all laughing and I'm like oh my
God I don't want anybody look at your
phone look at your phone
yeah
it's crazy out of your mind huh yeah but
it's there's something about that people
are like what if you die I go how would
I know I'm being put under how would I
know if I died why are you scared yeah I
put under I love it you love it too yeah
I love it I love it it's like a game
let's see how I can count this time you
know I've never gotten past four no I
didn't get past the one he goes count
down
um
okay I'd be your doctor and I said okay
so I said oh you big you real big look
at me let's go get [ __ ] psychology
hire Asians of Cedars oh yeah yeah but
uh but
um yeah proper form
and um
I think that's the thing that they're
using now primarily right yeah I think
so yeah it was probably yeah milk of
Amnesia they call it
because you don't know well what's crazy
is like all the fentanyl see in our time
or you know 80s 90s 70s whatever it is
you do cocaine you're probably not gonna
die unless you take a lot of cocaine
right you're not going to die off one
sniff of cocaine right but kids now
people are dying because there's
fentanyl in it right so many you know
people are dying so I'm like how could
you want to do that drug it's like a
Russian Roulette and a thousand times
stronger than hair so so
in even in high school like those kids
were doing it and they were they looked
like Skittles or something and they were
I mean just a little bit of can [ __ ]
put you out a little too much and a
little too much you're gone and
minuscule you know it's crazy you'd
think that they would be smart enough to
at least learn it's not like a dairy
there's no way you can tell what's in
there yeah you know but you're gonna get
loaded with this stuff and now hey you
may die they don't want to die they just
[ __ ] I can take it you know they're
they're taking a [ __ ] and it's
I would think that I would be looking
for another drug to get high I'd just be
afraid of dying and also their UPS like
you're on coke you're fired up you're
you've done Coke right no no I'm I'm
drug free okay by the way yeah yeah so I
was on uh Coke one night and I was like
you know I was but I was so tired but
wired this was like 20 years ago there's
a slogan tired but wired tired but wired
cocaine uh enjoy it powder your nose
today but
um I remember I go I'm tired I'm just
gonna take a Xanax my biggest no dude do
not be his Xanax right now it's like
going up and then down that's when you
get a heart attack that's when you got
to wait till you're coming down coming
down and maybe take something to sleep
and people don't know that I didn't know
that I could you know you could have
died it's crazy
[ __ ] you live a good life beyond me I I
did leave a good time now it's just this
stuff you know
the wife was we had an open house at my
house uh Monday night invited the local
sheriff's department the patrols my area
and the fire department come on in do
your house yeah just just to feed the
guys and you know tell them thank you so
four of the guys that were there are
cops Meyer they were off duty so we're
the only ones that are drinking and
pretty soon it went from drinking
socially now let's do tequila shots and
we're Shooters and now
getting loud and I got I got [ __ ] up
the fire the firemen were there they had
to leave they went to a heart attack
call they came back later on none of
those guys were great all the guys on
duty nobody was drinking they went to
the the call they came back they had
wife made him some uh chocolates we had
food for him we had everything it was a
nice day but booze if you could take
booze away from me I I bet you could
drink a half a case of beer like nothing
hey the only place I drink beer is here
I I drink uh mostly I'm a Wine Drinker
or whiskey but who decides what the a
person's tolerance is like everybody has
a different tolerance I think you also
build a tolerance because you see these
skinny skinny people who can like take
it back yeah functional alcoholics yeah
I I'm not I'm a lightweight now I don't
because I don't drink much but like I
have like a too whiskey and cokes I'm
I'm good yeah [ __ ] plus this weight
proportion height so I can carry a
little more plus I have built up a
tolerance but it's
it was a good night when we go on tour
you know like you like they go check
your phone the next morning who's this
where did she go what the [ __ ] am I
doing what's going on like you can't be
out there yeah I would black out fast
and you still look like you're
functioning but you're [ __ ] blacked
out that's the thing you don't remember
what happened right oh yeah yeah that's
the thing that's you could drink a lot
though no lightweight
couple drinks that's it
uh well you know if you get a doubles
you know so all of a sudden you've had
four doubles you've had eight maybe ten
shots that's a lot that's a lot it
doesn't look like it and they're like
man I was so [ __ ] up last night you go
you had four [ __ ] at the club at
Lakeside
I mean literally you you'll say can I
get a vodka uh and cranberry and there's
this much left at the top and the dude
splashes [ __ ] vodka in there and
you're like is that all vodka
cranberry and it's all
[ __ ] 14 ounces of [ __ ] vodka and
two ounces of cranberry juice just like
this is [ __ ] ridiculous you know what
I do I always now especially when I'm
older because when you're younger or
you're in college whatever you're in
Hollywood you know yeah you're like you
want them to give you more alcohol yeah
yeah my 15 bucks is going somewhere but
nowadays I'm always like hey just lie
down the light on the jack I want a nice
little drink right and I can be like all
right I'll have another light one and
ease my way into it if I want to I never
went through that period and I still
haven't gotten so you guys know full
speed let's go don used to drink uh
lunch with vodka quickies which was a
double vodka martini you know uh do you
do martinis they [ __ ] me up man that's
that Martini's out yeah martinis just I
don't know what the [ __ ] is in there
vodka and vermouth that's it though yeah
it's not even a big thing it's just the
glass and it looks girly [ __ ] you up
like a [ __ ] thing back then it was a
double vodka martini in a bucket so it
was in a regular bucket glass and
they were good you know and depending
where you go you go down to Chinatown
each guy you guys watch the mega Martini
he says Hey easy on the vermouth inside
a big Chinese guy and he poured it in
there and he said vermouth it never took
his thumb off the cat went like this
extra dry vermouth put it down here and
gave him his uh [ __ ] vodka martini
what's vermouth it's some kind of I
don't know Aaron what's removed
no one else goes inside it goes inside
you know it's uh I want to say it's just
a liqueur but all you do is matter of
fact I listened to a guy yesterday uh on
a tube say all you do with the vermouth
really for excellent Martini is pour the
vermouth in there swish it around the
glass and then dump it out you don't
even leave it in there you know they at
the club there
it's wine
fortified wine so at Lakeside
they make martinis that have a thin
layer I mean we're talking about thin
layer of ice that's not like when a dog
falls through ice and that guy goes and
rescues a dog out there like the lake
you can just you can just see it but
it's a veneer of ice that's when it's a
good one yeah that's when it's after
it's shaking you go in there it
shouldn't be cold enough and the isoform
on top
oh is that yeah oh that's how it is
Joe Pesci at the golf at the golf
tournament I have he goes hey George
you're having a martini like only time I
drink them but you feel they go fast
yeah and they're I mean it's good
but if I if that was my drink I I don't
I don't think I would last have you ever
been drunk at an event or something
where you're like how many no or
something where you're like you didn't
realize you drank too much and you got
to host this thing and it took me off
the stage one time
that's probably happened to a lot of
comedians tell me about that I want to
hear that I was I was supposed to go to
this thing later but I was at someplace
else and we were drinking and they go
hey you got to go over there they need
you oh they're running behind which is
the worst [ __ ] thing oh all right
they're running behind it hey and when I
got there I got to the side of the stage
it just it [ __ ] it just overwhelmed
me and I walked out there and started
talking and I stopped talking some more
and I was [ __ ] blacked out of that
[ __ ] got me and took me off
I think
oh my god I've always said it's my wife
she's kept everything together over the
years my wife has she's been pissed off
me so many times you know because of
drinking and if you ever piss yourself
no not while drunk
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like a [ __ ] cocktail back to my
[ __ ] quarters wherever they call
those things they're [ __ ] sweet and
I'm like oh man that's that's a lot of
uh [ __ ] pina coladas with with a
fireball floater
girl right I ain't my [ __ ] my [ __ ]
Fireball to see uh air [ __ ] ration is
off I mean [ __ ] destroyed oh my God
that's hilarious but do you did you I I
[ __ ] my pants just laughing at you right
that doesn't gross me out it makes me
laugh and you know just [ __ ] brush it
off
you know it's nothing that goes man what
you're embarrassed [ __ ] I've had
a thousand embarrassing that's just
another all right
I'll stay in tonight I'll go back out
tomorrow like nothing happened does it
affect you at all like if you bomb or if
you like get Dr whatever you don't you
don't you'll ever feel bad about it or
you ever feel embarrassed or you don't
care at this point you know what it is
man like I didn't know anything about
triggers or anything you know so so when
you do the shows like you try not to not
to drink and if you like oh listen Elvis
was still a drug addict and he would
[ __ ] leave while people were still in
their seats because if you go backstage
then the music starts then people come
in and then you start drinking and then
more people come in and now it's [ __ ]
1 30 and you've been drinking since
[ __ ] 10 30. that's why he'd get the
[ __ ] out of there and he was still a
[ __ ] druggie the only way for me or
guy comedian is not to if they have an
issue of drinking is to get the [ __ ] out
of there right after you're done like
leave don't hang around don't hang
around because even on the nights where
you had a tough night before just
drinking wiser show wise and then you're
going to get a little bit of a drink
before and then if it works out you go
back there and as soon as it's quiet for
two minutes you'll go as you want to get
a drink just a just a little drink
they're like yeah why not yeah and
that's it but if you can stay away from
the [ __ ] triggers of it
then you can make it do you feel like
you're better when you just have one
drink before you go on I think so yeah
sometimes just to just calm it down yeah
and the Hennessy had the Hennessy Black
uh when I did my talk show and they gave
me a couple bottles I didn't see black
and then I would have my suit on and the
ladies would be out the door already go
oh to come back I gotta leave something
I [ __ ] take that thing the [ __ ]
two [ __ ] full swallows and go back
out like that [ __ ] he's in a
good mood that [ __ ] fantasy black
when I was walking as long as you're up
yeah just two little flip-flop and you
know I know one uh and then all of a
sudden now if you don't do it then now
you're [ __ ] now you got your alcohol
[ __ ] and you're superstitious they'll
come on man they're you're running late
but I gotta I got no we don't have time
for that and now you're like do I do am
I relying on it it's like a sleeping
pill did he sleep well on a sleeping
pill the next night you're like uh I
don't know if I could do by myself
without the sleeping pill I have a
friend who's true big rock star man he's
uh I mean from the 80s like one of the
best guitarists ever and I was like how
do you just do it for people those
guitar solos and not he goes half a
Xanax before I go out every show every
show my entire life [ __ ]
he just it just takes him down a little
bit or maybe it's a quarter of Xanax or
half whatever just takes him down a
little bit you know it's like you start
relying on that stuff yeah but it's like
yeah that's not a good
you know those guys yeah I knew uh Eddie
Van Halen I would say man I would say
how'd you deal with hangovers ah I
didn't like what do you mean I never had
one you're like how do you never have a
[ __ ] hangover because I I'd stay
drunk and High the whole tour about
[ __ ] two years yeah
[ __ ] high for two years yeah that one
he goes remember when I was really
ripped he goes into like the early 80s I
just had no fat on me and I said of
course of course just [ __ ] just
because I had the deep I was trying to
quit I had the DTs
and I was still drugging so he goes you
remember my stomach how flat it was I go
that's all from the deep you're doing
crunches
you're doing [ __ ] crunches
all day
all-day dtn wow and just like man that
just sounds [ __ ] brutal brutal I was
throwing up at the at the peninsula in
New York
like at 5 30 and I was like in my head
what 9 30 I'm gonna be on on stage at
Radio City but at 5 30 right you're just
like [ __ ] what is this like what is that
yeah oh see then my wife still has a
long way to go
you're [ __ ]
sideways man [ __ ] side you're
sideways and you're still doing it but
you're [ __ ] sideways like all those
things you know those [ __ ]
Star is Born or I'm dancing as fast as I
can any type of [ __ ] movie with any
type of [ __ ] Show Business aspect
they you gotta write until the [ __ ]
rails they have to they come off or you
can't be good there's something about
like a [ __ ] Gunslinger you just
[ __ ] shoot maybe you get hit you go
to the next town you're [ __ ] on tour
you're this you're [ __ ] gone and
that's part of it unfortunately there's
no there's no drug or no alcohol that
that doesn't have consequences right you
know if there was everybody would take
it it's like that that movie you take a
pill and you're just and you're trying
to [ __ ] stay out there like on that
[ __ ] tightrope where you're like
higher than everybody else or like hold
this one and you pull it off and then
you pull it up again
and then at some point either goes away
or that goes away but you manage to kind
of stay connected to at least some
reality yeah so that you're not
completely [ __ ] lost and you can't
figure out why nobody wants you anymore
nobody's calling you and they go hey you
know how's the ticket sales oh man like
they had to cancel the second show what
and all that [ __ ] starts [ __ ] against
your head and you feel like I'm a loser
what happened and then you think
nobody's watching and everybody's
watching you think you're all cool
you're in the [ __ ] clubs you're
drinking and this [ __ ] and you're like
oh you're married and [ __ ] out there
and you go I'm in Sacramento who gives a
[ __ ] but everybody knows when you think
nobody knows everybody knows it's crazy
right [ __ ] crazy delusional it's kind
of delusion in your own mind you think
there's no there's no way nobody knows
what the [ __ ]
that's true wow that's just true people
try to keep them so I mean look it's
endless amount of people who try to
cover it up and they're I'm fine I'm
fine and you're like how is that guy
well I am I went to a treatment center
in Connecticut that was you know it was
life-changing but like
the person there before me one of the
biggest stars in Hollywood
I never heard he had a problem I never
wow I obviously never mentioned it but
like like really back he's got oh oh oh
yeah yeah like major major and what
comes with that is depression major
alcohol [ __ ] depression it brings you
down that's what that stuff all the
drugs when you come down it's the coming
down and how do you deal with that it's
like you know what am I doing you start
to feel bad about who you are
so many people go through that [ __ ] so
many people it's hard man even even in
[ __ ] police right [ __ ] heart Bad
Lieutenant there's some guys that are
out there that are right [ __ ] crazy
do you have some of those guys there's
guys that are out there that kill
themselves you know they go to
depression they go through suicide you
know they do a lot of stuff uh I haven't
hit rock bottom yet I don't know I you
know I've never but you don't drink
every day
kill drinks every day I don't drink
every day I drink a lot of wine I don't
drink at my house I got more [ __ ] listen
I would consider myself
I was not as much anymore but from 2000
well 2017 [ __ ] five to 2013 maybe a
functioning of maybe an alcohol Maybe
well it's good you could at least say it
because you could say it you know so so
Maya you know my daughter comes over to
my house you know and she's like are you
an alcoholic and I said what
are you an alcoholic I said what do you
mean are you an alcoholic
I said listen
I don't need you to worry about what I
am okay or judge me for whatever like I
drink and if you're so [ __ ] concerned
about whether I'm an alcoholic or not
then [ __ ] don't take my money then
and it's silent and she goes you're
getting a little bit overheated let me
go get you a beer oh my God as soon as
you start saying well don't take the
money okay I went too far don't worry
never mind yeah I wonder what I was
thinking well no one wants to hear it
nobody there's no there's no way that we
were gonna have a discussion about
whether and well let's talk about it
inside shall we what if someone asked to
ask you about it what if it was like
like a close friend you wouldn't want to
hear it either no [ __ ] never see that's
like when I watch those shows like
what's it called Intervention you watch
it they're like I'm getting the [ __ ] out
of here [ __ ] you yeah you're like oh my
God you [ __ ] suck my dick whatever
works
with your [ __ ] talk is I was a kid I
gotta not grow up with [ __ ] problems
the girls inhaling the air that you
spray to clean off your desk they will
stay The Office Depot out they [ __ ]
throw you out what get the [ __ ] out of
here who's that you got it she takes the
[ __ ] computer cleaner
get the [ __ ] out of here you gotta hit
rock bottom yourself they even have that
put away if you go to to uh a [ __ ]
Office Depot that people go in there and
buy that [ __ ] and you they get [ __ ]
high off that I had a sister that died
at the age of 47 she was a stone of the
bone
alcoholic
she used to
drink that ship your sister yeah found
vodka bottles underneath the bed uh she
was where did that come from
uh I'd like to say her husband you know
her husband were drinking and they were
partners and she just became a stone to
the Bone do you think that's something
she was the nicest one in my family and
they tried an intervention with her and
I wouldn't have any part of it yeah she
was the nicest one in my family and I
said I can't do that you know I'm not
going to go there and sit there and beat
the [ __ ] out of her you know bash her
because what she's done you know will do
something else and and she was the good
one huh it was the good one she was nice
as one in the family but I don't think
like I think you know the the idea is
the concept of interviewing because they
love they love the person sure they
don't want like we love you we're not
judging you we just we want to help you
but when you're that far gone or you're
that you don't see that you think people
are ganging up on me it's just like you
know yeah it's hard sometimes it works
but a lot of times I don't know but yeah
I didn't get a phone call I'd get a
phone call from stranger hey you don't
know me but your sister gave me your
card told me to give you a call here it
is she says you'll know what to do this
is where she's at and I'd go pick her up
and and I got her into a couple of
facilities the last time when you said
hit rock bottom she had been in Beverly
Hospital for almost 30 days in a coma my
mom was working there at the time had
gone in there didn't even recognize her
and finally she found out hey that's
your sister they told me I went down
there and I'm visiting her and
rubbing her hand and at one time I'm
just sitting there saying I love you
you're gonna pull through this I love
you it's okay and she came out of the
coma and that was Rock Bottom she came
out of the coma they had already told
the daughters you know do you want us to
resuscitate you know don't let her go
doctor says that's as good as she's
going to get right there and so we made
all these Arrangements that she came out
of it and she got herself a job cleaned
herself up she went to work for this
company she was so good to the company
as a secretary they gave her a couple
job secretary receptionist
because of her work the company had made
a bunch of money off of what she was
doing for him they chartered a bus they
took everybody to Vegas
uh
for a weekend and they picked up the tab
and the dogs already said if you ever
drink it again three months is what
you'll get
and she went the biggest fell off the
wagon since of course and she lasted
about three months after this
[ __ ] you can't go to Vegas when
you're ready come you got to go to the
[ __ ] uh Florida
Alpine Village or some [ __ ] where it's
not happening you know well we didn't
talk about the Berry Farm it was hurt
you know I go to Vegas she was good she
was dry it was her choice nobody else
knew about it but she got on she went
she fell off and she lasted about three
months and then she finally passed away
and I just tell my mom hey it's not your
daughter that's not Sylvia you know it's
not it's not my sister that's the devil
you're messing with you know there's the
demon has her the demon is the booze the
booze and so she passed away at 47. I
said she's no longer suffering but
wasn't her husband that was her husband
that was a bad influence if she was the
good one yeah she was he was a I won't
get into what he was I don't even know
if he's still alive but he was also an
alcoholic at the time yeah that's the
thing if you live with someone who's
enabling you it's just back and forth
it's like it's never going to get better
[ __ ] never if someone's there that also
likes to drink with you right you're
[ __ ] and then I don't think you can
[ __ ] drink excessively with somebody
that's either your a girlfriend a lover
whatever and not fight like you're gonna
fight because alcohol is gonna make
gonna [ __ ] just agitate some what did
you say yeah what did you say I didn't
say anything what did you say could you
listen you don't want me to [ __ ] say
what I'm gonna say what are you gonna
say and then you [ __ ] drinking and
then you say something you don't even
know you said it and now it's on yeah
nobody's a good drunk very few people
nobody yeah it's true
it's true I'm a good girl I'm I don't
know I'm happy all the [ __ ] time here
that's the way I am over there you don't
go drive you don't do anything until I
get there till I get tired then I get
sleepy
I had this fine ass chick one time in
the limo you know we [ __ ] go on the
casino and something that we were
drinking we play golf we were drinking
and we said we'll meet up later on and
then all of a sudden she's on the gets
in the other side
and I'm looking at her I said you all
right and she's like silent
and you can kind of see her like the
light's not on
and I'm looking at her I'm like are you
all right and you can still just see
your
just looking straight ahead
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
Amy what's going on I turned the light
on she's sitting in the dark like this
just put I said what the [ __ ] is going
on just I try to light off this is what
I see
are you like is that for me
all glazed over
she kept drinking after we dropped her
off hey we'll go
clean up and we'll go she kept drinking
so she got in the car she looked okay
just out of her [ __ ] mind yeah
and try telling someone when they're
drunk that hey I'm gonna get you an Uber
it's just a small thing like that hey
let me get you just like why will you
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I don't need a [ __ ] Uber are
you kidding me I'm like well I think
you're you know you're drinking a little
bit it's like [ __ ] they don't want to
hear it they don't want to hear that
they're drunk or they're out of hand
I've had some friends where I'm like hey
you're not driving and they're like
[ __ ] you seriously are you kidding me oh
my God are you what can I record you
talking right now you [ __ ] idiot you
know what I mean I've ubered I've called
made it bad I know I'm going to a bar at
this bar and so I'll Uber from there
don't worry about it you know I'll just
Uber from there we were following this
person in the car and and we said you
know I still remember the window was
like this open we went in and said you
all right to drive it's like yeah it's
not that it's not that far I'm okay and
we're like all right but we'll be right
behind you and she's driving all of a
sudden we see the car go like a little
bit of like that and we're like oh oh
man that's not good and they were coming
around to turn and she went straight and
hit a [ __ ] tree
and on both sides of the window [ __ ]
powder came out
like [ __ ] snot
you all right yeah and just shot out the
sides
the cops come yeah we took we took off
we left her there that's what I was
wearing what happened about that we left
her we were [ __ ] laughing we were
laughing and we go over to the things
you're all right she's like what
happened [ __ ] shit's still in the air
the [ __ ] uh air back Dustin
I literally got [ __ ] 11 minutes
I was gone in 11 minutes it [ __ ] came
back wow what happened no it's it's not
working out
wife does a lot of driving for me and we
just went out Saturday night want to
listen to the Mavericks play and we went
back to this place called Stephen
Steakhouse
have a nightcap and got the she doesn't
she just doesn't drink much at all and
she just says you want me to drive home
and I said yeah here most of the time
I'll give her the keys when we first get
there I can hear you driving but you
know what let me ask you this if she
doesn't drink much right and you're
drinking a lot you're probably the horny
one oh I am well he's probably like
Jesus guys another drunk yeah
right at my retirement I mean you can
imagine [ __ ] somebody that's
completely sober you're just like you're
a kiss with your mouth all open with
[ __ ] [ __ ] no [ __ ] wet around here
you're all into it and they're they're
just like oh you know they're [ __ ]
completely sober oh picture their
nipples
you like that you're like definitely
more oh my God
yeah
the cheese
you think she likes some cheese
oh man I can't imagine you're [ __ ]
completely sober and you're [ __ ] out
there [ __ ] wild you both gotta be
buzzing you can't you're completely
sober in one drunk person that's just
not right when I retired
sucking a dick I'm a dude that's not
gonna remember
I was the last time I was what you know
I don't like to do that do what
right in my retirement
I had shot glasses made and I told Jimmy
when I get up there to talk I want your
waiters Shout at the Gila and every one
of them just pass them out get them out
there and the sheriff was sitting right
in front of me
and I got up on stage and I started
talking I just started saying hey you
know
for those of you who don't know me
I haven't had a drop of alcohol I hadn't
I said I haven't had a drop of alcohol
in over a year
I said don't worry I didn't do a [ __ ]
Chicano that's a lifetime yeah I said I
didn't know I was like what I was like
what I haven't uh I didn't do anything
stupid
and I didn't get in any trouble
but during that time
the undersheriff every time a cop would
get popped for drunk driving or getting
because they get popped just like
everybody else and they got popped and
say well another another guy caused
embarrassment to the department got
pulled over by CHP was arrested and and
he was always putting this up in the
teletype for us you know like scaring
everybody you know to make sure because
now you're going to get burned and it
was chicken [ __ ] what he was doing so I
got this I said I knew anything stupid
and I hadn't been in any trouble
I said truth of the matter is I haven't
had a drink in a year I said but
I said the realities are I just didn't
want to give Larry Waldy a shot at
catching me dirty so cheers
you went out like that huh let me ask
you this have you do you think a lot of
police officers when they pull another
cop over
if they're drinking they let them go
it's like a Brotherhood well they they
in the old days Not only would I work
the rough areas So Not only would you
let cops but citizens because we had
better things to do than take the time
to arrest a drunk driver so you'd get
their keys throw them in the trunk of
the car or hey do you have anybody can
come pick you up or take them down to
the local wind chills drink some coffee
when you figure out how to get back to
your car you're good enough but you
can't do that anymore because now
cameras cameras all over the place some
guy got his ass kicked when they did
that here in East L.A got his ass kicked
and sued the department because he
should have been arrested same thing
city of Industry they let him go two
blocks later he got in an accident
should have done your job so they don't
do that anymore what they might do with
cops what they might do
uh if you're not an ass because cops can
there's nothing worse than a drunk cop
when he's an [ __ ] uh they just hook
you up take it to jail like everybody
else if you're Cooperative you go along
with it they'll just let you go they'll
put you in the backseat of the car take
you to the station they won't book you
they'll take you to the station and
either have somebody come pick or have
your boss your Watch Commander from
wherever your sign come and pick you up
yeah you're going to get it here for you
may get some time off but you save
thousands of dollars you know and
attorney fees and then the drunk thing
so but they don't uh they don't mess
with you too much no ever since no they
don't
mad the old days I really have to
[ __ ] the liability is what changes
and you let somebody go and you get in
trouble the department you can so just
don't yeah even when when a when a
restaurant wouldn't cut you off
and then you know until someone uh left
you know and killed somebody then that
then all of a sudden you go what were
you drinking at then they started to put
the place responsible
for that person like you see they're
clearly drunk and you keep serving them
and something happens like you could sue
everybody's getting sued I find more and
more today maybe just because the guys
I'm good they drink with I'm like
home uh we have the guys that are here
with now maybe they're because it's more
responsible you find each other
saying hey I'll give you a ride home
I'll take you home or hey can we call
somebody for you or Uber you know and
more and more people uh are doing that
today than they were before that's all
because of Mothers Against Drunk drivers
you know they got out there and I
started damn drugs again and mad mothers
but we uh
we we don't we try to drink responsibly
you remember in high school these that
people come speak who like killed
someone or drinking driving you have to
sit in the auditorium and listen to
their stories and go oh my God yeah
right and no one listened yeah nobody
listened nobody they'd be like ah Who's
laughing George
yeah
and all of a sudden it's like you know I
kill someone [ __ ] all right I'm
here trying to save you from oh all
right like everybody's laughing what am
I saying [ __ ] everybody starts They're
laughing more I'm like I'm not even
saying anything They're laughing more
the guy's like if you're gonna waste my
time and go thanks a lot George I didn't
[ __ ] say anything
I'm just [ __ ] started I was chuckling
what the [ __ ] it's so scrunchy they're
not forms and they don't they don't
listen they don't know I mean there's a
referee that just died this last Mills
Lane Mills Lane [ __ ] great guy a
great guy great guy I'm in a homicide
convention and he's the keynote speaker
let's get it off and I don't know what
yeah he's the one that started let's get
it off yeah uh I'm sitting there at a
table with drugs the guy that broke me
in at homicide finally had to pick me up
come on come on let's go let's get out
of here made me get up and walk because
I couldn't stop laughing Mills Lane is
up there trying to give him a nice
speech I don't know what the [ __ ] these
guys were doing to make me laugh and I
couldn't stop laughing they [ __ ]
walked me out
now I'm working on the Night Stalker
case so I go up to San Francisco on a
Case right and Carl klotz looks at me
and he says I know you you have you ever
had a I said I've never had a case up
here
he said he's never been the same guy I
said never been to San Francisco on a
case at all and did we work something no
never and then somebody told a joke and
I started laughing
and he says [ __ ] it the homicide can
[ __ ] oh my God
he remembered me from my laughter his
partner Frank felzan the one that came
on and he comes in he says hey Frank
remember this guy Frank says I don't
know the guy he said no take a good look
at me so I'm telling you I don't [ __ ]
know him
and he says watch this he tells a joke I
started off he goes the [ __ ]
convention you want a Night Stalker case
yeah wait a minute I know that I think I
saw a documentary urine yeah documentary
[ __ ] dirty Hamill [ __ ] haircut
I did I was like wait a minute I've seen
it yeah
it was star I'm just you're not the one
that pulled him over no I never pulled
him over didn't he get like uh he was in
a street or something he was in a street
tried to carjack car they got him they
beat him and then held him down the cops
got there took him jail but also how
about there was another guy that they
pulled over that had underwear in the
car and that was the guy was just a
[ __ ] deviant yeah and right that guy
they didn't have same Theory they didn't
have YouTube and whatever you the porno
on the internet then because when we did
a search warrant in his house all he had
was pictures of women right out of
magazines you know if they were modeling
Sears catalog and he had women's
underwear that were cut up in the crotch
uh the guy was a freak just not my freak
oh my God so you actually spent time
with yeah The Night Stalker like talking
to him yeah
it's fun it's impressive did you
honestly he was the first guy he was the
first guy that said it's one guy
everybody else is like it can't be one
guy he's like no I'm telling you it's
one guy
and everybody's like they were like he
said motherfuckered me up and that
[ __ ] guy that's always talking about
because one guy and what let me ask when
you looked in his eyes like everybody
says when you look in the eyes you see
the devil what did you really see when
you see him was he just a guy honestly
another human being
that's all he [ __ ] was you know we
everybody that's probably one of the
biggest we've we're afraid were you
nervous when you went in there it's like
a quarterback going out there game day
during the week he's a [ __ ] drunk
he's a family man goes out with his
buddies Sunday puts on his football gear
football player it's football player and
everything is nothing you never would
have thought this guy did this stuff oh
I don't yeah I thought he did when I
went in there I knew no no but if you
didn't see all that stuff and you met a
guy on the street would you ever look at
this guy and think something's off with
this guy no no he was the most
articulate murderer I've ever
interviewed
and [ __ ] I spent
26 years working murders did ever see
any dark [ __ ] to you
well you say dark [ __ ] he he said
something that is very in in line with
sex we talked about [ __ ]
and he [ __ ] at one of the houses and he
said you see it I said it was a dog turd
I said no he said there was no doctor
I'll tell you exactly where it was
and he told me that he says that was me
and so he that was uh he took he took a
[ __ ] and and killed someone at the house
and killed someone left somebody for he
left them for dead they didn't die that
was the young girl that was the one who
got him or like eventually no no and
then when he caught him he said did you
see it and he goes I saw it I thought it
was a dog that was me like like that
playing that [ __ ] game yeah and then
then uh damn he called McGill I called
him rich
I mean and then like he stayed at the
Cecil but he didn't have anything in the
room like he had a locker at the bus
station and that's where he would he
would change clothes so if you went to
the Sea so the viewer a cop and you go
can I look in room 507 did he take you
in there you go the guy maybe shoes or
whatever and there looks fine
because he knew that's how [ __ ] smart
they are they're gonna go to the room
they're gonna [ __ ] bust me he went
and got a locker at the Greyhound bus
station and he would go in there and put
his [ __ ] kill clothes on and whatever
he needed and then go do his [ __ ] and
come back and change back and then be
back in there and then had they find
that he was going to that lock they just
followed him or no he had in this person
he had a ticket
we had an informant that told us he was
hanging around the Greyhound bus depot
he'd come and go that was that'd agree
that's not fast I don't know why that
stuff fascinates I have horrible
nightmares a lot I have bad nightmares
and a lot of it
probably is from watching these [ __ ]
shows do you scream like you wake up I
don't wake up I just wake up and go oh
my God I get asked that all the time why
do you think people are so fascinated in
watching all this [ __ ] yeah and and I
don't know but then you you stop to
think horror movies that's what I love
horror movies or years ago
everybody wanted to go see the horror
movie they want to go see scare the [ __ ]
out of them and they still do if it
scares you it's good and
that was a sign of sexual deviant one of
the things that with Richard that's not
true though yeah it is but watching
horror movies no no not watching
horrible I was like oh [ __ ] scaring
people is a sexual deviancy so scaring
he would he would stick a gun in your
face and watch you [ __ ] he didn't want
to kill you you just want to watch his
[ __ ] in your pants he wanted you to see
your skin how about that like that girl
like the girl that it was kind of by you
right they shot the Latina girl no they
shot the Asian girl they shot the Asian
girl they shot the Latina first shut up
she lived she's the one that went around
the front yeah and then he comes back
because she could okay so the solar he's
in the he's in the apartment he's in the
he's in the kitchen down the chat the
Japanese girl duck down yes and then he
waited on the other side of a countertop
he said he tells me she was stupid she
put her hands on top of the countertop
because it was quiet she was waiting
nothing there and she pulled her head up
like this to see over the countertop he
was on the other side of the countertop
like right there waiting with a gun for
her to pop her head up dude shot her in
the head
and he had already hit her in the back
of the head with a gun and knocked her
down
left her there and then came around this
side just waited for her to come back on
you know man I
it's crazy because you know I like
horror movies and I like the adrenaline
but and some people say oh maybe it
helps you cope with maybe coping with
death if you like watch these things
then maybe your death won't be as bad I
don't I don't know if that's true I
don't know what that's I don't know what
it is
and I always watch them since yeah you
know since I was young but like I
watched these series that my friends go
I watched one episode I can't I had
nightmares the Dahmer Series yeah yeah
did you see it yeah it's one of the most
disturbing things I've ever seen well I
started watching it I watched The
Butcher he [ __ ] he's eating it art
we've never seen that [ __ ] on TV I never
said that was that just it felt like
what you were watching was real right
that was it was I started watching it
and then my wife came in the room and
I'm watching this stuff and I said oh
okay I'll change it you don't have a
bunch of stuff and I was looking at
totally analytically you know I'm
looking at it I want to see what the
guy's doing what he did and from the
police side of me
and she says no no leave it on I want to
watch it so she starts watching it she
said oh how gross how can you watch this
stuff and I told her I said dear I said
I used to do this [ __ ] for a living this
was
what I did I came
so I just changed it never went back to
it right but you've seen some dark yeah
it's dark to to most people it's not
dark you know because the doctors do it
yeah right doctor a doctor does all this
[ __ ] and it's not uh what about what
about when that police officer opened
the refrigerator and she's a head
[ __ ] screamed yeah who wouldn't
scream a cop the [ __ ] cop scream in
the movie no not me [ __ ] screamed in
the movie uh he was like what the [ __ ] a
crazy cycle yeah Cycles based in theory
on a real movie uh gains gains yeah and
he used to kill bodies cut them skin and
use the skin for lampshades Furniture
coverings yeah and so the cops
and the first cop that went to see him
he went nuts he was in they had to put
him in a
you know yeah yeah they did they give
him your [ __ ] head man they get in
your head
yeah see I I'd look at see ahead well
the first thing I'd do is just back up
okay let's see what's around the head
you know look at his scientific well not
because it startles me and listen like I
might go you know that's another I mean
that's but also the thing that I find
so it's like three in the morning and
you hear a noise or do you and his
family moved out he's like you guys I'm
on myself move out because who knows if
this guy's not going to come over here
oh that was yeah yeah I remember that in
the documentary right yeah yeah and that
that really happened so he's in the
house and you hear something I
psychologically I just wake up I don't
know what it is so he's in the house
with his back to the wall with the with
a gun he's trying to clear the house and
the phone rings how [ __ ] high would
you jump at three in the morning that's
a horrible when your mind is like this
and the phone rings yeah
[ __ ] that dude I mean
the phone rings your head you're not
even thinking about the phone you're
like do I [ __ ] hear something oh man
you know I that thing you didn't have a
security system no no you know now I
have a security system I got a big dog I
got a bat I'm getting a freaking shotgun
you think it's a good idea to have a gun
in your house uh as long as you're not
afraid to use it and know how to use it
yeah I wouldn't be afraid to use it if
somebody broke it's not it's not a bad
idea you live alone
uh yeah I have a dog I have a lot of
friends over a lot but yeah I live alone
it's true yeah how do you like it that's
lonely we're you know it's a little bit
but but
if you hear I mean it's crazy right if
you're crazy if you're here shall we
hear things in the house and I wake up
like that I'm in the house
it's a big [ __ ] could be the backyard
it could be the side of the house I have
cameras outside yeah so I see it right
there yeah you know you set your alarm
before you go to bed oh yeah yeah I
gotta start doing that I set my alarm if
I'm gonna sit down and watch the TV I
was just like I'm in for the night I'm
setting my alarm no one's coming over I
lock my door my alarms you know what the
[ __ ] I don't want to do that I'll [ __ ]
get your gun off yeah my alarm is
what the [ __ ] my cameras are up the dogs
are yeah
yeah usually if people hear a big dog
barking they're saying like that's
really kind of why the dog racer said he
used to get along with dogs he wasn't
afraid of dogs mine I think he'd be
afraid of
I know it's kind of like um
the dog is the best because they're it's
really the best of the [ __ ] thing
they can hear somebody outside
walking by or smell them you can smell
them yeah
you know
the ring camera caught a couple of you
know because I live up a hill and then
there's you know over there kind of open
what's your address uh P22 go by your
house P22 was around the name so so I
caught
a couple of people walking by the middle
of the night they looked
[ __ ] demonic they look [ __ ]
demonic there was a guy walking the
middle of the street skinny and he long
arms and he turned like that and it
caught him and his eyes caught the light
and you're just like with a [ __ ] wig
on you're like this [ __ ]
that's that's [ __ ] if if I opened my
door and that [ __ ] was like
excuse me you live here I'd [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean
hey you left it like you left the car
open
every [ __ ] I mean they look [ __ ]
weird man yeah weird [ __ ] weird like
like [ __ ] I out of the not even like
a [ __ ] human I've never had
a problem knock on wood but I live by
the Los Feliz murder house up the street
oh Jesus so go ahead no but uh
I was doing some performance out of this
band and uh we were playing it it's
called the stages it's like a live
virtual show and we're playing and we
ordered food and it says leave at the
door and so after our performance we
open the door and there's no food there
so my friend gets on the you know phone
bitching at the people what the hell
Uber and where's our food she's like
here sends the picture I left it so then
I go back up on my camera and I rewind
and you see this guy he's just like
comes up takes my bag walks away he had
like six other bags with him he had
walked on down the street and he just
looked like he was somewhere else like
just it was kind of freaky it's kind of
it's you're violated a little bit you
can't feel like what the hell you know
and uh you're like all right what other
creeps are gonna come in and you know
what because you hear about home
invasions and [ __ ] yeah what usually
tell me
who's
vulnerable for a home invasion usually
what do these guys look like anybody
they mostly go at a certain house like
because it looks like there's no
security no cameras Richard said the
only thing that kept away from going
into a house was a good security
and what is a good security just one
with a [ __ ] sign out in front of your
your friend you know my home it's enough
alarm yeah that's a deterrent other than
that nothing and he just picked houses
at random other Hypes and you know
they're just looking for easy easy makes
you know if your house looks tough to
get into they probably won't bother you
never had it you know they drive around
a lot of them drive around during the
day just see what it's like during the
daylight and then they drive around at
night to see what kind of actions inside
the house you know if they can see
inside the house if they can't and some
they just in fact the lady uh that was
in the documentary Linda Arthur she was
a uh she's worth crimeless youth deputy
and she retired as a lieutenant from the
Department
she lived right across the street from
Sophie Dickman who was one of our rape
victims
and her husband got murdered Linda's
husband got murdered June 1st
Sophie Dickman happens on July 7th so
Linda's got some friends staying down to
staying with her for the time being
and she hears the lady yelling Mrs
Arthur Mrs Arthur because Sophie knew
that Linda was a cop so they come and
she was found uh with her wrist
handcuffed to a four-poster bed she
drugged the bed over the corner and to
get into her house he went in through
the back you know he had to jump a fence
go in there went through a cat door
pulled it out of the slider pulled it
out and then that's how he slipped on
okay man dude so you know he just
everything was random and these guys go
uh I don't think you're gonna find it
it's logical you're not gonna if you put
bars on your windows like some people do
you're probably not going to get a
burglar inside there but short of that
you know and especially if they're going
in and if they're loaded the time they
don't give a [ __ ] about anything
thanks for that again I know I think
yeah yeah it's true right yeah but alarm
signs
and the guy you know it's like eight you
know what we're thinking right now ATT
Brinks goes backwards so I could see it
I'm about to see it for and and
president of the company either at T
brings one of those big alarm companies
he was at a function
and uh
you met me and he says you know what I'm
going to give you the best alarm I've
got so before I go today he said remind
me I'm gonna give you the best alarm I
got and I'm sitting there thinking [ __ ]
I'm gonna give me a nice electric alarm
put it up the house and he gave me what
he gave me sign a sign he says best
alarm you could buy you don't have to
waste your money on everything because
they don't know if you're lying or you
do have exactly they're not going to
take the chance
and Richard said I wonder what's the
percentage of people that like you lock
yourself in or like me that have it but
don't lock yourself in it's on your
phone
it's easy to do
I can do it right now just make sure all
your shit's closed up and you say
watching TV you hear something I mean
they're gonna take off yeah
my house before we had uh before we had
alarm systems and all that my house was
burnt rice
and all it did was piss me off I told
the wife I said well next time just give
signs up on the walls hey value books
are over here don't [ __ ] up the rest of
my house
and the only thing they did at that time
was they stole the only thing worth
money in me was uh they took silver
dollars and my dad had left me they took
several dollars and the uh my grandkids
their little Banks you know I had
changed them that was all do you think
that it's somebody in the neighborhood
because it's not how could it be random
yeah it was it was it was somebody you
know what's crazy is you like
you've seen so much you've seen kind of
like unaffected by everything but like a
doctor like you said your analogy was
right so I I'm just curious was there
ever a time early in your career where
things did get to you where you had
anxiety you woke up in the middle of the
night things were affecting you or it
just never affected you never affected
me I'd come from I'd been in combat
already you know before I was mad once
you go there you've seen that so I was
just I mean the only thing I've learned
through life from Vietnam
you panic you die so if somebody panics
somebody's going to get hurt seriously
hurt or die so
I
always remain calm do you ever have that
adrenaline but your comp but at the same
time yes but you're like you're aware of
everything yeah yeah and and I had
something diagnosed early on uh they
said I had someone who's called
vasovagal syncope yeah this is faint
right yes exactly and that's caused by
how do you know what that is stress
because I had it once I was uh faint
well it never happened to me and she put
this needle and she couldn't get in she
kept jamming it in and there was like
swelling and blood and I don't know what
happened but from my my mom whatever
something happened I went
oh [ __ ] oh wow and it was the scariest
thing that ever happened to me I mean it
took a while I was blind I felt blind
and then your sight slowly comes back
but they say it's not abnormal it does
happen and that's caused by stress my
lack of sleep and so the hours that we
work in in murders are tremendous so uh
and stress you know whether it be stress
from work stress from home
you know it was uh it was knocking my
ass out you know what I can't understand
when you watch those shows and you see
them taking them into the interrogation
room and there's that camera up in the
corner and you're watching them
why does anybody talk to a cop it
doesn't work like you get a will you
know all that stuff for TV that's so
people can see that's really not the way
it is and when you talk to me when I
talk to Richard I talk to him just like
I'm talking to you right now but why
would anybody like even say I'm gonna
talk I want a lawyer because I'm the
nicest guy in the world when I want to
talk to you and I'll convince you that
I'm a nice guy and I want what's best
for both of us not just you not just me
but also he said that once he got caught
like his whole uh magnetism left like
his whole
that's just a [ __ ] guy now he's just
a guy he's out there [ __ ] Terror and
and once they get they get him like it
all kind of went away yeah
wow it's like Weinstein right yeah I'm
Mr Blue like this guy and then now he's
just the old yeah he reminds me of the
guy you talk about are in the the
cochino the uh run Jeremy Ron Jeremy
that's what YC reminded me of Ron Jeremy
you know [ __ ] wow he he really was
like a
like a thug to people yeah like he would
just be like we flew with him to New
York and he had his wife and his kids up
there and then when we land he's like
hey will you take a picture with my
daughter she wants your picture I don't
know why she'd want it but can you take
a picture with her you're like yeah but
just to be a [ __ ] ass I have a dick
you know it's funny I know a story from
ins like somebody who worked with him
closely but like he was such a dick he
had this meeting it was him and his
brother his partner and the other guy
who kind of runs the company but his
brother said something and he just went
over to him and punched him in the face
and knocked him out in the middle of the
meeting just went up to him and just
went [ __ ] and punched him in the
[ __ ] face knocked him out and that's
a true story [ __ ] crazy man that
whole business is gone right Miramax is
[ __ ] dissolved it's always gone yeah
I mean that guy was a [ __ ] predator
and he what did he rely on the fact that
nobody would talk he's Untouchable you
wanted money [ __ ] don't say where you're
done you're done
you know that's money sick yeah it's
sick man yeah and by the way I don't get
away with [ __ ] ain't got no money ain't
got no power but it's amazing like you
think you get some success you have some
money finally you're able to do the
things you want to do
why would you right you don't need to
where's that [ __ ] Darkness come from
I think he's never happy no he's never
happened that's where it comes from it
comes from childhood yeah there's some
[ __ ] that went down and this child are
guaranteed right you know I it's like
something happened I think the third
burglar ran into him when he was a kid
do you think so he was sexually abused
burglary Jesus what the hell is going on
here turd burgers
and that about wraps it up like a punk
rock band a turd burglars I think yeah
that'd be a good name hey uh uh what is
are you left-handed I am left-handed
yeah did you know that because you did
the guitar but you did left-handed where
do you play bass you play guitar I play
acoustic guitar and similar you just
have a band it's called Sun spin out you
know what's funny is like I always
wanted to sing I always wanted a band I
always want to write music and I thought
well I don't sound like Adam Lambert I
shouldn't do this [ __ ] I'm not a great
musician like and I was like why don't
you [ __ ] do it because you love it
right so I started doing it and I we
have our third albums coming out in
February you know what man I I was I was
looking at it yeah yeah yeah what's it
called the man's called Sun spin yeah
it's me and my buddy Rob dancing and we
I'm proud of it it's not like an actor
you know an actor's play and they have
CDs and they usually suck I honestly
don't I really don't think it sucks I
honestly don't oh yeah good because I
think people will dig it and what kind
of acoustic guitar do you have
um electric two were most acoustic
mostly acoustic what do I have you right
there and you write the music yeah right
all the lyrics and the songs and and Rob
helps me like you know add Bridges and
things and but you know what I was
looking at your your your bio you know
and you've done a lot of you've done a
lot of stuff a lot of shitty stuff too
but also but also but if you look at the
progression like the shitty stuff led to
the to the better stuff voice over stuff
and then led to like Batman and Lex
Luthor you know but that stuff is like a
stepping stepping stone on the way up
which which you want I think you want I
don't think you want to hit early and
then the shitty stuff is after yeah I
didn't have overnight success no you
know I was I was one of those guys that
just kind of like did this small part in
a movie and then from that I did a
little bigger part and then a smaller
part and then all of a sudden I got you
did some TV some TV and then you know it
just kind of so I'm proud of my career
but um you know it's
it's crazy because you know I grew up in
Indiana small town southern yeah and I
never thought I was going to be anything
who moved to Indiana because your
grandparents got divorced my dad was
they were still married at the time they
moved from New York to Indiana right and
you know it's uh we were like the only
Jews on the Block but how was that how
did they move from what was going on my
dad got a job transfer for work at
Bristol Myers right and so we went from
like low class to lower middle class to
hovering right under so it just you know
he worked very hard and um yeah so grew
up in Indiana and then was College in
Kentucky and then moved to New York and
everything kind of started happening but
as a kid that they would it was a
different if you were Jewish back there
was it different than the only thing I
remember is one person threw a quarter
down the and said fetch to my sister
once oh hey Jew fetch I remember that
the other thing was once that's fine one
guy goes said something about Jewish
some Jew and I'm by the way we're not
even religious regardless we're
respective yeah I respect everybody
and I just go yeah he says something
about being Jewish or something I go you
know I'm a Jew
and the guy goes [ __ ] off you're not a
Jew I go
what are you kidding me of course I'm
Jewish Rosenbaum you're not [ __ ]
Jewish look at you you don't look like a
Jew you're not a joke exactly
I mean it was like an argument because
he wouldn't believe that there'd be a
Jew where we grew up wow so but you know
usually no one
really said anything if they said
something it wasn't like out loud
um but well I remember happy Hanukkah
yeah thank you and I remember there was
one black guy in our high school
out of like 400 people
just one black guy and he was one of my
best friends yeah you know
um but I was I was the most unpopular
shortest kid
couldn't get nailed in wood shop kind of
guy I just was like you know what am I
gonna grow it was just and suddenly
something started something happened
when I graduated high school I started
to grow and I I thought I was going to
end up working at a grocery store my
whole life making five bucks an hour I
was I was like all right this is cool
this is what I'll do I make a living
somehow and uh people always say like
you know how'd you do it I'm like well
it regardless of how good you are or
because it takes a it does take a lot of
luck yeah it's it's a combination of
talent luck you know how that works yeah
but but what led you to I mean your mom
was a writer my mom kind of wrote like
in small town papers yeah interviewed
like baseball players who we always
thought she was sleeping with Wow but
you know you're always like what what's
going on you were you were in Keith
Hernandez's room a little too long
like that yeah she would interview but
just for a small paper she would get
credentials to go in there she didn't
know what the hell she was talking about
but she was a good writer and my dad
worked his ass off uh you know uh at
Bristol Myers a pharmaceutical company
and
you know I was just it was kind of like
we had we were very dysfunctional you
know do you have a lot of dysfunction
that's all yeah is your mother still
alive yeah she is she is she you know I
look I love my mother but like you know
I also take care of my mother and right
but it's you know it's not did you play
the guitar back then no I didn't start
till after college or whatever wow yeah
but you went to college I think that
kept I wasn't gonna go to college you
know I went to college
because one of this popular kid who
lived down the street Tom Lally still my
best friend today WoW known him since he
was 12. he lived down the street he was
popular he hung out with all the popular
kids he played on the football team I
was just nobody and he used to come up
every once in a while just say what are
you doing man
then we'd hang out a little bit or shoot
baskets and one day he comes up so our
senior he goes hey what are you doing
are you going to college I go uh I don't
know he goes you should room with me we
should go to Western Kentucky and I go
this popular kid wants me in a room with
him I should probably take this
opportunity wow no [ __ ] and I went to
college because he it's sad but like I
was like oh my God he this but I went to
college and he was the guy who's like
dude he's so funny watch his impression
of Jim Carrey and Fire Marshall Bill
watch him do Malkovich watch him play
and people started to gravitate towards
me and I I became sort of like popular
and I started doing theater and and it
gave me confidence you need someone in
your life that helps give you confidence
I think that's true because I had none
but I also was hiding behind a facade
that I was talking about it was like
you know because my was your father the
kind of guy who says I love you George
oh I didn't know my dad but my
grandfather was not biological so no no
you
why are you laughing at Gill what the
[ __ ] is this what happened what's so
funny no my dad's my dad never did say
uh I love you
but what is happening [ __ ] this
is so [ __ ] hard to say he never said
that he never said I'm proud of you he
never said that was my dad I was just
that was my stupid
on his deathbed when he's dying I had
never said I love you dad I made
everybody clear the room when I went I'm
gonna grab his hand I said dad I got
something to tell you he says what's
that son I said Dad I love you
I want you to know I love you Dad
and my dad said me too ah yeah but
didn't say I love you said even on his
deathbed even on his death yeah the next
day what the [ __ ] is that I told my
sister I wish my dad I wanted to hear
him once say I love you you know just I
know he did but I just really want to
hear it
and she came in about a half hour later
she says you question your dad how much
he loved you
she says we were going through the stuff
in this in the closet and there in a
metal box
was ten thousand dollars all the
insurance papers deeded the house tax
information money for uh the ten
thousand dollars for my mom just to get
my mom was working but just right now
just
have it available
and he had it all wrapped up in this
newspaper and there was a newspaper you
opened it up and it was an article about
me when I was
helped starting an orphanage in Vietnam
and I was asking for help from lawyers
that's not what your dad loved you
wow and so it still affects you yeah
yeah it does you know what's funny is
say that thanks for sharing that man
you know I gotta say that my father [ __ ]
my father
wrote me a a card recently and I could
tell that he's gotten better over the
years like he's still you know it's just
old school God damn but he sent me a
card and it just said
um you know I just want to say I'm proud
of you
are proud of the person you've become
that's what he said except for your
farts
that's what he said I could show you
I'll send you a picture of the card
except for your fart yeah fart you know
the director of uh who doesn't [ __ ] you
don't fart Aaron
yeah except for your farts he [ __ ]
threw it in there did it mean less or
more it kind of like lessened a little
bit I kept the card you know what he but
he he had to put something happen in
there yeah yeah but he had to take it
away he had to put something in a little
takeaway yeah and I I think he's I'm
proud of who you've become
[ __ ] except for your farts [ __ ] I get
it okay I gotta put something else in
there that's not enough the director oh
man right Netflix yeah I think so I
think
the guy that did the documentary I
called him up about two weeks later
and I said okay I just want to thank you
it came out far better than I ever
anticipated I didn't want to see any of
the rough Cuts I didn't want anything to
do with it you do it you work your magic
I'm just a talking headpiece so when it
came out I watched it like everybody
else I said I want you to know
and he knew about my relationship with
my dad
and I said uh it made me cry made me
laugh I said and that one part I said
subliminatively I know
you were put in there my dad's proud of
me I said I know he's proud of me now
and this one especially this one photo
and he said well let me tell you a
little secret he says while we're doing
the rough Cuts while we're doing the
editing into here he said when we showed
that I stopped it admittedly turned on
all the lights and everybody in the room
was crying wow he says that's when I
knew this was going to be good I think
we all have it we all wanna we all want
to make our fathers proud it comes from
so many people that it's it's very
common but why but what what's the
[ __ ] why what's the [ __ ]
negativity toward your kid wanting to do
something like if it's some other
[ __ ] kid call this [ __ ] kid over
here wants to be a [ __ ] race car
driver [ __ ] cam but when it's your own
kid you can I mean you made it you made
that kid you can't say like hey whatever
you do I'm [ __ ] behind you man yeah
you know I don't think you can do it but
prove me wrong [ __ ] it I think there's
some I think there's some competitive
thing there especially like you know he
works really hard he always worked from
seven to six at night never missed a day
at work I bust my ass like that and now
you know I think there's maybe I don't
know I'm speculating but like maybe it's
like oh he's an actor you know it's like
and it's oh he's making a lot of money
and maybe there's some competition maybe
maybe it's old school maybe his father
he didn't really have a great
relationship with his father there's a
lot of stuff you know I forgive him I
I'm totally there you go
so Edward almost told me that he Edward
almost played baseball like in the 60s
he was really good
but then he was into music like he was a
good singer he was a house fan at
[ __ ] uh the whiskey in the 60s the
[ __ ] doors and everybody
um wow and
his dad loved him when he played
baseball
and then you know around 14 15
he's like I don't want to play baseball
anymore I want to do music I think I was
doing it for my dad and I just like Hey
Dad I don't want to play baseball
anymore his [ __ ] dad didn't talk to
him
or you want to play baseball anymore
that's [ __ ] and when he was dying
he was already a [ __ ] Academy
award-nominated [ __ ] actor and his
dad's last words were get a real job
[ __ ] imagine that's his [ __ ] last
thing he said to him get a real job see
I mean I didn't have to make my mom I
don't know what that is there's
something you're taking that with you to
your next when that's what you leave me
it's so easy to just say
I'm proud of you I want you to know I'm
incredible it's easy to say hey I love
you man I know it sounds Goofy and like
whatever but it's easy to just tell
someone hey I love you
it's it's not that hard that [ __ ]
years go by you can't get back you can't
get it back yeah yeah you think they're
gonna live forever
and they don't you know you know what's
[ __ ] my friend said this at his
wedding he spoke at his wedding and it
was emotional
um and he said something like
for a long time
I and I can relate to this he felt like
I know
logically intellectually that people
love me that some people really love me
I know that
but I don't feel it
and it was really it hit me because it
was like I know like you know
my friend or my friends
they love me I know my dad loves me I
know but it's weird it's like sometimes
you just like you just don't feel it you
don't understand it it doesn't make
sense because again you you know it's
logical but you don't you can't but also
when you when you when you came to this
business and you're going out and after
you're done with your side you throw the
back of your car whatever there's all
kinds of [ __ ] papers back there and
you're driving across town to go
audition for this
and you're trying to get something but
then all of a sudden you can't imagine
having that house or having that career
and back there it just seemed like there
was nothing to [ __ ] hang on to
nothing there's nothing to next day
you're like well I can go do there was
nothing to [ __ ] hold on nothing to
hold it's it's a miracle
it's amazing it's a mirror place to park
you're [ __ ] late you're gonna clock
you got to be in there you're running
across this [ __ ] paper in your hand
no you're like [ __ ] know then you
keep going and the next thing we're
gonna do now rather nothing and you get
a call you go to Santa Monica and you're
out there just trying to get a [ __ ]
spark to the [ __ ] light
for somebody to say yeah come back in
you come back in maybe you don't get
that one but they remember you hey I
remember you guys yeah you read first
over here now it's this it's it's
[ __ ] like that it's it's the odds and
it's on somebody else not on us it's
somebody else that sees you that
remembers you they go I like that guy
bring him in yeah I think he's right for
this it's not us yeah it has to be
somebody that you connected with or they
saw something and then they said bring
them in here I think he's right for this
you come in you go hey
somewhere else yeah you know what uh
it's crazy because I think there was a
period of my time a time in my life
where it feels like there's some people
that start to believe in you and they
believe in you more than you believe in
you like you don't even have the
comments you're like you still have that
inner child from way back going I wasn't
supposed to do that I'm an idiot I don't
[ __ ] how am I him even here I must be
I'm that's why you always hear that oh
I'm cheating the system I lied you know
they're gonna catch me they're gonna
catch on to me I'm not that good and
they believe in you and that's that's
this pressure too that you have now you
have to please them you have to be great
it's a it's a childhood it's crazy
that's what's good about my life there's
like two childhoods
it's another set of players I feel like
I'm the kid I'm enjoying my yeah same
issue yeah yep that that's what's so
good about my life today because see I
never had to go through what you guys
did looking for that next job because
that was gonna be your career and you
have to work you have to practice run
around through Santa Monica and do it I
had me a job study job I retired
and then all of a sudden they did this
Netflix thing and I've always been a
speaker I've spoken all over the place
this Netflix came out and then all of a
sudden the world just lit up and people
are now coming to me you know they want
me to do production here they want me to
do this they want me to do it and if it
happens fine if it doesn't it's okay
because I'm still just the guy I was
before I started and you know yourself
yeah and who you are the best part of
this whole deal honestly not because I'm
kissing anybody's ass was meeting George
and coming on this podcast this it's
it's fun this is fun it's fun just being
here and I and I met a friend you know
I've got a new friend
so I'm half up I'm half had covered in
the last couple weeks so I had I was
half asleep
watching the documentary
forgot about who it was and they said
Farley no no and he said the guy buys
things that he likes they take the place
of people so he's surrounded by things
he likes and not surrounded by people
and I'm like what the wait a minute wait
a minute and it's I have [ __ ] guitars
all over my house I bought [ __ ] 20
guitars in the last since August dude
and you just got to come to my house and
I mean it's like a museum [ __ ] you
know what I mean at a museum and I was
like oh [ __ ] I think that's
I think that's me
these things in our friends or your
friends yeah I I completely understand
if you came to my house you'd be like
you get it right I have these toys I'm
like a 50 year old guy I have like Star
Wars stuff and guitars and autographed
posters by uh you know what's his name
Gene Hackman yeah and like all this it's
just like it makes me happy
I think it is and you know what it's
crazy listen another guitar hanging
there's this guitarist hanging on the
wall
I lay in bed I can look I could see him
nobody's leaving nobody's coming and
going where you going you're coming back
I don't know they're there yeah this is
a Solitude solitary business anyways
gotta be by yourself you're not working
on any material with somebody in the
room you're gonna be [ __ ] by yourself
what are you doing working on this thing
I'm doing can I help
of course not
okay oh okay well I'll you know it's
just that it's that way it sucks too
because you're proud like me is you love
being alone but you hate being alone at
the same time it's it's it's a it's a
[ __ ] you want someone there
but it's a it's a crazy bat like you're
50. my therapist said because I he knew
that I had issues you know and he's good
he's like 40s not so bad 50s it gets a
little bit worse
60 okay now it's it's gonna start to
donate 70 forget it 80. [ __ ] you're
the guy with a cataracts eating [ __ ]
soup at the [ __ ] Norms of the last
hey Google
Mr [ __ ] Hollywood you're [ __ ] eggs
what happened to him yeah that
[ __ ] are like this [ __ ]
you know but it's
it's like in the hell [ __ ] it's
me yeah what happened to your [ __ ]
guy that's amazing but when you shaved
your head did you think it would grow
back I mean your [ __ ] head was shaved
to wear every day it was like this
however he played Lex Luthor in a
Smallville yeah
his [ __ ] head
like like if you saw an egg and you
thought there's hair could grow there's
no way hair could grow out of there I
mean right it was [ __ ] it was and you
have a good you had a good head too
thanks but I'll tell you what in
production you had to be like that let's
say the Laker game oh my man must be
sick
Maya
so what happened what happens is you
know if if crew call is at seven where
the whole crew comes on cast screw call
by 7 30 they'll start to gather
everybody for a blocking eight go get
makeup
I'm there at 5 30 in the morning or 5
a.m two hours before anybody's even
there [ __ ] amen shaving me sometimes
cutting me and putting like three layers
of makeup so you see no hairline right
and then so I was kicked you know kind
of Caked Up at times and it was like it
was lighter hot and smooth like yeah
sometimes they got it right in some
episodes you could look and go over
there but most the time they got it
right and but it was uh it was all even
it all wouldn't even colored yeah it was
look they paid you well it was a you
know I got a lot of
you know a lot of attention yeah yeah
it's cool man I just you know
um it was worth it now I still go to
conventions and people are still love
Smallville right you know it's a new
generation and you know there's some
things in the works maybe I'll maybe
I'll bring it back who knows do you
think you you know because James uh like
he he went over to from Marvel he went
to DC right yeah him and Peter saffron
and now they run in DC right yeah and
that's a that's a that's a that's a
heavy Crown it is and they're they're
doing great and they knew that they were
going to have some you know people are
on that showing and saying hey what are
you doing and with the Henry Cavill
thing and I think you know they have a
plan and this is the plan that they so
how do you travel with Superman right
and he said on Instagram I'm coming back
I'm gonna be Superman
and then the guys took over D.C James
Gunn and Peter saffron and their plans
were different and they made him go
and asked him to on social media say
you're not gonna be Superman right is
that what happened I didn't even know
that and you you you we need you to say
it yeah I think ultimately because their
plans are different they just had a
different it's like hey these this is
what we're doing this is what we want to
do and we have to stick to it whether
people like it because we really believe
in the end this is good for DC so that's
sort of where they're at and like all my
friends like James is one of your best
friends you were you know you introduced
him to his wife you you're gonna be the
New Lex the music no no no no that's not
how it works you know it's like hey look
I'd love to be considered I am I old
enough am I whatever yeah I mean I think
but he's pretty good about putting his
friends oh yeah yeah if they're right
for it or if that's what his vision is
yeah but like I don't ever go oh you
know he better or I'm just like hey I
hope he considers it but he's he he um
because I was one of the best skill I
don't know if you ever they say he's one
of the best one of the best like it's
like it's down like but also but but
also was he a comic book nerd like you
guys would comic book he was a big comic
book yeah I wasn't I was uh I read
fengorian horror magazines I never did
read anything but but you almost like
for him to be in a position like that
you have to have been reading comic
books when you were [ __ ] like you
have to have accumulated all these
things like Aaron has in his house
you're like what the [ __ ] is that
that's not that's the [ __ ] Pegasus
from the such a son it is Cyclops
[ __ ] you have all this [ __ ] that only
you can understand and only you can
explain what the [ __ ] is that well I
don't feel aware of The Fifth Element uh
I'm not okay anyways so you have to and
then you get to a position where you
where it meets the usefulness and the
information you have now is gonna
[ __ ] look what he did with guardians
of galaxies encyclopedic knowledge of
that stuff like nobody he [ __ ] is one
of the smartest guys I've ever met
um he's creative he also has a heart of
gold the guy is just the most giving
um
and people love working with him and
he's just he tells it how it is and he
you know he opens up about his flaws and
things and he's just a you know he's
look I think it's going to be great I
think it's going to be a big success I
mean look what he did with Marvel with
Guardians of the Galaxy you're right and
then he did The Peacemaker right Suicide
Squad he brought back that everybody
loved and now he's you know so it's like
hey he's kind of weaving gold here yeah
let's see what he does with DC it's a
lot it's a lot on his plate like I could
I couldn't see I couldn't deal with that
that [ __ ] near that kind of price
crazy man I can barely deal with
anything right yeah you know what I mean
I mean I got stressed [ __ ] tons of
[ __ ] in the air
at the same time and he's like uh Hey
[ __ ] hairs up you know yeah [ __ ]
thing cool casual still looks like he
enjoys his life he does things like hey
come up for New Year's he's just like
he's just a dude you know he's a dude
that knows
comics and is passionate and he loves
music all those movies had great music
that's all the music yeah a big part of
that and that guy that took over the the
guy that took over Warner Brothers from
Discovery so the Warner Brothers
Discovery like that dude
is like he cut Batgirl they already
spent 60 million dollars on Battle
Michael Keaton he's like that's off the
[ __ ] off the table that's not gonna
happen he [ __ ] did that replace that
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is this
guy doing what the [ __ ] this guy's doing
so I did Blue Beetle and blue beetles
going uh
in in August like it survived and even
Blue Beetle in Puerto Rico
all the producers came over and the
writer came over got a little meeting he
goes hey so that you know the Warner bro
Discovery you know the new guys in there
now and he's seen all the work and his
first question was how far along are
they because you know the [ __ ]
like
I shut it down
and he's like how far along are they and
they saw it because I'll give it a
chance
and then you see the other stuff go away
it's still it's still going right good
so so Blue Beetle there was nothing
about Blue Beetle anywhere and I say to
James on his Instagram I said hey
welcome the welcome aboard the bug ship
captain you know because they've been up
in the movie there's a bug shipping it's
got legs like a bug you know
and he's like wait you'll see wait till
people see how good you are George from
him and that and that went viral
that was all over the [ __ ] and he means
it and that was all over the [ __ ]
world his first that communication on
Instagram was [ __ ] went by like it
was all over because they're so thirsty
for [ __ ] information did you tell him
I was your acting coach I told him
that's awesome yeah he's a great guy he
really is and he's so vocal on those on
social I know it's crazy it's the last
time he's talking to fans he's like no
that's not gonna happen this is we can't
say anything or we're working on that or
this is why that's not true he's like
you know his full transparency and also
it's like you can nobody would think
that he would have time to still pull
fans in and that's what he's doing yeah
and he does that he's pulling he's still
making them connected to it goes oh I
thought you were into the DC nah not so
much anymore I mean you know they went
but that [ __ ] he keeps everybody
engaged yeah that's [ __ ] amazing yeah
it's amazing it is amazing yeah I'm
happy for him and what are the comic
that that fandom is a is a it's
different than Rock Fans or different
than movies no it's just I'm telling you
when you're in that sci-fi world or that
you know Marvel DC
it's the gift that keeps on giving
become beautiful and as long as you're
you know I love my fans they're so
supportive I have these these patrons
for my podcast that support the podcasts
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum but
we also have a talkville podcast yeah
that's with Tom Welling and we we
re-watch episodes that I never even seen
and we talk about them and we have all
these listeners we have fun doing it
it's like revisiting we go to these cons
you can't if you're not on like a Sci-Fi
show or have some kind of following like
Luke Skywalker or Star Trek or
Smallville or Superman whatever there's
some but like
it's like there's this built-in audience
so you go to cons every year have a
great weekend meet fans make some money
if you but also you wouldn't want to go
to a con if you didn't have the juice to
be on a on a good level on a plateau
because they'd be like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing here you have to be like
up on the up on the on the way up like
you have to have some a show that people
want to do instead of just being like
hey you did a couple of episodes like
Believe It or Not sometimes they'll have
Star Trek uh cons and they'll have
people who did one episode and they'll
come and they'll make some money they'll
do people who are a couple episodes on
Supernatural they'll come at like a
Supernatural come going to this it's
called creation Con on January like 14th
and 15th in Vegas and it's like all the
supernatural guys like Jensen Ackles and
Jared Padalecki and me and Welling are
going and it's like
there's a concert tonight it's an event
it's it's I'll tell you what it's fun as
hell they have those things for they
have a crime con
they have a crime con yeah I did a crime
Con in Vegas this last year did they pay
you yeah
that's true and what are they what did
you talk about bonocha no yeah you know
they they called me I did the crime call
a year before in Austin Texas uh it was
a last-minute add-on they needed
something they called me up they said
hey your name's come up would you would
you do that so yeah so I went down to uh
I said what do you want me to talk about
I said you got 45 minutes why don't you
talk about
your career you know how you started how
you're in how you end up with a nice
soccer case just 45 minutes all right
that's no problem so
we go to Vegas and they said hey we'd
like to do it again I said do what we'd
like you to come back and speak
I said what do you want me to speak
about he said well same thing you talked
about last year and I said well wait a
minute you know there I said well no no
last year there were 1500 people in
attendance that was kind of coveted
we've already sold over five thousand uh
tickets for this and I said okay so yeah
so that 3 500 people that haven't seen
you before says the others will either
come or they won't but hey we want you
back would you do it yeah okay I'll do
it and I said you want me to speak about
he said same thing he did last year I
said all right I hung up the old lady
says uh so are you gonna go I said yeah
and I said what are you going to talk
about it same thing I did last year so
what did you talk about last year I said
[ __ ] I don't know
I just moved your life yeah went up
there and talked the night before I'm
doing a thing over here in Vegas they
were with I said well so what are you
gonna talk about I said I don't know
figure it out when I'm up on stage yeah
and that's what we did uh first song
ever I got a standing o
and all my even think about it and and
my wife uh because it's sponsored by a e
so that everything was professionally
done timing done the clock's right there
and they sent me a copy of it so I sent
it I let the wife watch it I said this
is what I do when I go out there and
when it was done I said what'd you think
she says it was all right but do you
have to make fun of me because I talk
about my wife yeah who doesn't I said
yes hey humor gets your point across
yeah people pay attention when you're
making them laugh or so that's what I do
and so they do have a crime con and
they're worth great over 5 000 people
there and they're not crazies you know
they're just people in a true crime yeah
he's done a lot of Animation you could
easily go oh yeah yeah animation stuff
you've done a lot of voices right right
yeah
you could go and say and they'll have a
big picture and they'll say oh you know
all the characters pictures on there
George Lopez yeah we go have fun I
always say try it out see if you like it
if you've been to one you haven't been
to one no I see we'll see what the when
the Blue Beetle comes out let's see what
yeah if anything is a good time yeah
that could be a good one that's cool
it's a trip man because you know you
start out doing comedy and then we're I
really can't I don't know if I can say
anything so but when you see that actor
crash through in the suit and you're you
know I did a sitcom you know and and you
see the the actual suit for the first
time and you're standing next to it and
the guy's inside and you're like
pretty [ __ ] cool man yeah like the
dude's in the suit and it's not doing
anything it'll light up and [ __ ] will
come out of his back those prongs and
you're you know but he's just standing
there
it's like
do you are you prepared to for what
might happen doing this he's in the math
not not really but I could kind of feel
it and you the whole bug [ __ ] purple
whatever blue he was really secretive
about this [ __ ] I don't think we could
talk about it he couldn't talk about he
couldn't do anything wow we had no idea
we were doing Zoom podcasts yeah he was
over there uh on the set never knew
anything I learned more today about the
thing that I did I love it I can't wait
to see that the uh you still go to Laker
games I just went to one
um last week I went to the Nuggets when
they beat them how was it it was a blast
you know but you went when the Kobe you
won the Kobe era in the Kobe challenge I
got I got a shout out Genie bust not the
names I always have a gamer if I do a
job I just right just drop something uh
but you know it's funny because I met
Jeannie at a party
so many years ago like when I first was
like new to LA and I just got Smallville
I I didn't I'm oblivious I don't know
basketball at all I've never been to a
basketball game I didn't know anything
about it and this woman and her friend
come up to me and they just start
talking to me and they're nice as ever
and I'm like hey Paula okay we watched
the show and I'm like oh my God that's
awesome and we talked for a while
just thought she was whatever a fan yeah
and she goes oh here's my card just call
me if you ever want anything or want to
go to a Laker game I go okay okay cool
thanks and my other friend who's an
actor comes over goes dude how do you
know Genie Buss and I go who's Genie
boss he goes
Jerry buss's daughter dude I go
who's Jerry Buss on my mother's life I
did not know I just I'm I didn't I know
hockey
and and she goes uh
because that's jury bus is doing to the
Lakers and so about a month later I just
emailed her and I said hey Jeannie you
said to ask if I want to go like or get
my love to got four tickets valet
it was the first time I'd ever been I'm
like oh my gosh and then she invited me
again and after the second time I I'm
telling you this was a dream come true
didn't you go on Christmas too this was
20 years ago I think so yeah but she
goes
Michael I'm not kidding
whenever you want seats ever
to any game
you just email me or text me you have
tickets with you and your friends
forever and I was like I just it was
like Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory wow and I don't go a ton but
like I text her she goes yep you're in I
already got you here your tickets are
gonna be sent later I mean she's just so
awesome yeah yeah and it was just
because I was I was nice and I wasn't
you know what I mean because you're so
nice she didn't yep
did you meet the doctor
Jerry yeah a long time ago like I would
see him in the chairman so you met him
you hung out with him I'm [ __ ] best
man yeah but I hear that they don't they
don't I mean he'd I mean they don't make
guys like that anymore like you know he
knows what he likes Swagger and like
[ __ ] Swagger the [ __ ] hair or the
thing you know the belt buckle [ __ ]
all young Latinas here Dave George come
and settle over my friends hey what's
going on you know exactly thanks a lot
Jordan but of course doc anything for
you and uh they're all the same height
they all look alike and then my
daughter's in there oh but this one
comes with me she's in there where's my
bike get over here but it was like he
was he had a he had a [ __ ] Swagger
had a [ __ ] presence that and he was a
great guy like I hear my friend Alex
worked at a bar years ago and she said
he would always come in and he was an
absolute gentleman and always tipped
really well and was so friendly and kind
she goes that's exactly what I remember
of him and she would tell me and she she
loved him so he I mean look people
people love Jerry boss that's what crazy
thing about you would see some Lakers
outside of the Chairman's Club some guys
after the game maybe they're [ __ ]
Harper or like Derek Fisher those guys
in there [ __ ] Kobe never
yeah never saw him in there like he he
came I don't know whatever he left and
whatever he had no
part of him was hanging out did you did
you ever get an autographed ball from
him oh yeah you did yeah they gave away
these balls it was like Kobe night in
his first year and they just everybody
got a gift of a Kobe signed autographed
basketball and I took it home thinking
I don't really know a lot about Kobe
yeah they became one of the best players
in history yeah they still have that
ball yeah on Christmas day they would
give you a voucher for shoes everybody
everybody Courtside would get shoes what
so they're like there's like shits that
collect Grinch those all green ones and
there's one that red white and blue but
every whatever he wore everybody got
his Christmas Day shoes everybody got
and at halftime you'd go and get them
and bring them back to your seat and put
them on I mean do you ever just like
every once in a while just kind of step
back and go it's pretty [ __ ] amazing
Funk absolutely I I do that too I always
just go God how did this happen
how am I doing this [ __ ] did it God
it's [ __ ] nice to meet you my
pleasure thanks for coming in this has
been a real treat this is fun thanks guy
I really didn't know what to expect and
it was just like three guys talking how
do we do it yeah pretty good huh I just
I forgot I was even being recorded yeah
[ __ ] I just was like oh it's fun man I
think you know I think it's more
about
like that like
just more of just like we all find
Mutual things to talk about but you know
like music he's trying to play the
guitar on yeah I'm taking lessons
nowaday it was a you know bucket listing
yeah you pluck two at a time you know so
I always wanted to I always want to do
that so now I'm taking lessons I mean I
just want to learn how to play it I want
to for yourself for myself and then see
if Goa contacts me uh Goa of course I I
know you I'm a big list but George told
me go to those of America that's that's
what Goa stands for yeah you you might
get your uh oversized belt as membership
the uh but
but also I get my star
my stock in the alley I should put some
of the [ __ ] alley back there uh but
you played what the sacks I played yeah
so he played in the band he played the
sacks that's great so so
did you what you didn't pick up the
guitar as a kid you picked it later you
know what's funny is my friend was
taking a lesson and he'd come home and
he's like Almost Heaven West Virginia
and I go oh Bob Denver give me that and
he goes oh and I take his guitar and I'd
flip it over because I play upside down
and backwards oh yeah that's just how I
learned like he goes dude what do you do
you can't learn life you're upside down
I go I know but just show me that chord
the G show me the C and then it became G
sharp and all that and I learned upside
down so whenever I'm playing with like a
professional they're like whoa It's like
a rare thing I just flipped over a
regular guitar and learned how to play
that way I I think you get the high e is
up the highest at the top
whoa that's just how I learned I don't
know why I was stupid oh what the [ __ ]
is wow I mean yeah I've never you seen
that
it's super rare though I know it is he
plays it upside down yeah it gives you
more of a bass sound too instead of that
tinny sound because you're playing down
on it [ __ ] hey man like Hendrix
played a guitar upside down but strung
for him right with the low E on top and
the high in the bottom his is the
[ __ ] things upside down yeah it's
crazy there can't be anybody that's ever
done that like I've never heard of I
think there was some wasn't there
there's a few but not many not maybe not
many there was a golfer that chipped
[ __ ] like this and he made one and
won the tournament because that's how he
learned oh my God everybody's trying to
do a shit's all [ __ ] going sideways
like he had his hands backwards and Chip
and you're like oh look at that it
[ __ ] went in and he won like one
chipped it in to win and everybody's
trying to do it it's like you can't do
it I remember I was uh I was a guest on
some like New York station for some
press or something and in the uh there's
this guy you'd almost want to see that
if I was like somebody bring a guitar
over here and you God almost want to see
it I mean I'm not a great guitarist but
I can all but
you could probably do all that [ __ ]
right
but so I was in this in the waiting room
and there's a guy and I didn't really
look at him there's a woman in the room
this black guy was over here I'm over
here and I look up coming up next Richie
Havens and I go
okay with you Havens oh my God that's
Richie Havens
oh yeah Woodstock open Woodstock open
Woodstock Freedom oh yeah and I went up
to and I go
ah man
and he had his guitar with him and I go
you know and he he was just showing me
some chords because I was just learning
that and his hands were so big he used
his thumb he was always in the studio
yeah and it was just like it was
legendary man Richie Haven just sitting
there that's crazy [ __ ] man
that's awesome Richie Havens man that
was that other um Peace Train no is it
was it
Peace Train
I saw Cat Stevens when he came he
performed at Microsoft and he didn't
perform in a long time it was great uh I
saw him too somewhere yeah man I Loved
Cat Stevens he did uh uh
um
oh yeah and then he would sing you know
another set but he's Muslim so he would
take all the stuff out that was like
anti you know I'm trying to get a date
no no you know it's a bat out yeah he
was like oh man come on come on I always
see those cars I always go to those
concerts like I love Kenny Loggins is
playing or Michael McDonald or at The
Canyon Club you ever go to The Canyon
Club and there's like no it's just a
bunch of old folks is that Beverly Hills
no no no
there's one in like Santa Clarita yeah
but you go there like the little river
bands playing yeah yeah yeah OKO or 10
CC I love it like that [ __ ] yeah I love
it I go I went and saw you know Ted I
know Ted Nugent like I go see Ted Nugent
and take all the dudes I went to high
school with and we go see him and he's
like here's one for you to Lopez play
Stranglehold he's got the [ __ ] thing
you know and uh or we saw
what did we go see over there we saw him
but really any anybody yeah it's one of
the Cheap Tickets you should go there
it's really fun I love gone there
because it's like people don't even
bother you it's just like a bunch of 50
to 80 year olds drinking and they got
[ __ ] good good bands of the babies
and [ __ ] all of them [ __ ] great Rick
Springfield right uh Air Supply
I love that [ __ ] I saw [ __ ] Air
Supply at the amphitheater this girl
made me take her and I'm like this is
some [ __ ] at the end I'm [ __ ]
jumping up and down [ __ ] pumping yeah
they have some [ __ ] milk in the air
look at myself what's your favorite Air
Supply
oh man um
[Music]
they had the country club in the valley
in Reseda
and I saw Jose Feliciano I saw a tribute
to the doors where the guy looked like
[ __ ] gym I've seen that one I I went
to the [ __ ] look like Jamal I think
he it was well the age he would be at
the time [ __ ] oh my leather pants I
mean he sounded like him he was
mysterious I go I got another guy he put
the belt yeah and he had this open shirt
with the beads and his [ __ ] hair and
he leaned down his [ __ ] eyes were red
as [ __ ] I'm like I think that's him yeah
I did too [ __ ] eyes were [ __ ]
realized let's do as high as a
motherfucker's eyes were all red I saw
Jim Carroll there [ __ ] Jim Carroll
wow yeah
Jim Carroll man this guy
[ __ ] what was he like a what kind of
music was it like it's not Punk right it
was Jim Carroll
[ __ ] I mean Jim Carroll my friend
Ernie got me into Jim Carroll he had
some [ __ ] wild asses we saw there uh
what's his name Billy Ocean wow he was
phenomenal this was only like four or
five years ago everybody was like all
right Rosemont I'll go with you I got
like 20 people and I'm the same he had
[ __ ] hits dude you know his hits get
out of mind into my car yup yeah and he
sings suddenly wait suddenly song goes
he's saying Wanna Be Your Lover you love
her yeah yeah yeah uh
Cara being quiet
commercial right here
that shit's [ __ ] I love that [ __ ] man
if he ever comes in town you gotta see
Billy Ocean man they're all out there
they'll be sad songs
[ __ ] Aaron didn't know any of this [ __ ]
all right man thank you brother dude
that was [ __ ] awesome that was
[ __ ] awesome that was so much thank
you it was fun thanks
you do a Rodney that's right no no I
didn't but you do Impressions oh I'm
spot um
hey I'll tell you what
I said my wife told me to take out the
trash
[Laughter]
that was good she likes to talk during
sex sometimes she's coming from a motel
my wife's cooking so bad the Flies
checked in the picture screen
I'll tell you my wife she's a bad cookie
I hope we pray before we eat
I'll tell you what another what is it I
went into the what the [ __ ] did he go to
he says uh I went to the doctor I said
oh the dentist they said my teeth are
yellow he said get a brown tie
[ __ ] amazing man he was [ __ ]
awesome did you ever meet him oh man he
was the [ __ ] of course you met him
was he always like that too yeah hey
George good to see you hey
nice tie all right that that they were
backstage been any uh faborito these
guys and they were about to at Bally's
and he'd go and they were talking and
everybody's laughing he goes then all of
a sudden it just got quiet
and Rodney's like what's going on he
wants a [ __ ]
four guys now we all want to get blown
it [ __ ] hangs up hey we're all
getting blown
[ __ ] [ __ ] called up just cause it
low in the conversation like what are we
doing I love when he says he has one he
goes yeah my wife and I decided to smoke
only after sex she's up to three packs a
day I haven't smoked for 10 years
[ __ ] amazing I always like I was a
nerd I used to sit in my room just
listening he's a Johnny Carson with
those [ __ ] see-through socks like
those old pin socks and black knot you
can see his leg through the socks oh
yeah he's [ __ ] amazing father issues
daddy issues yeah major I read his book
yeah he just wanted to make get his
father's approval his whole life they uh
there's a picture there was a picture of
Bally's in the air he's in a rope he's
always in a [ __ ] rope and the guy
goes look at his hand and he had the
joint cupped back like like this because
look at his hand he's holding a [ __ ]
joint in his hand so always smoking weed
everybody take a picture yeah all right
come on
he just puts it behind
[ __ ] puts it behind him he's always
get away with anything back then right
yeah I was gonna say that's what he
would do he get away from get anything
hold on hang on real quick hang on real
quick because there's uh
oh if you go to this thing you can go to
Rodney Dangerfield quotes have you ever
read those boom they're [ __ ]
top 25 quotes right
when I was a kid my parents moved a lot
but I always found them
I asked my wife on a scout of one to ten
how do you rate me as a lover she said
you know I'm no good at fractions
[Laughter]
favorite
I told my psychiatrist everyone hates me
he said I was being ridiculous everyone
hasn't met me yet
right they're just genius you know
I was at Bally's and uh I went down
there before the show but I think he had
like a private in in a in a hall
and the guy goes hey Rodney's up there
go let's go see him do we open the side
door
and we go in there
and he is just like [ __ ] throwing him
boom boom boom [ __ ] crowds [ __ ]
crazy and when you don't think it could
get any crazier he go to the store in my
life no I mean and it [ __ ] stop that
[ __ ] thing man I've never seen
anybody kill it like that or like that
laugh laugh laugh laugh laugh laugh
laugh
laugh
people holding this laugh laugh where
can it go from here but to start my life
no and [ __ ] unbelievable I heard
Howie Mandel was got well it's like
people like that with him that'd be so
true yeah maybe yeah anyway dude I love
it I love it
yeah this was a blast